welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the second season of killing Eve
has just had its worldwide release on
iPlayer
after debuting last month in America and
if you've been keeping up with the
villainous adventures of villanelle and
you'll know that there's a lot to bat
from the show
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the season 2 finale and giving my
thoughts on why the show could go down
the line this is full spoilers ahead so
if you don't want to know what happens
in the finale then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of killing Eve season 2
killing Eve's season 2 is pretty much a
mirror of the finale of the first season
with Eve being wounded by villanelle
instead of the other way around killing
Eve has basically become about well
killing Eve and the season ends on a
huge cliffhanger that ties back into the
title from the beginning of the season
villanelle was on the run from mi6 and
this run was basically about her trying
to reclaim her name and claw her way
back to the top by the end of the 8
episodes run the titular Eve and
villanelle ended up working together in
order to investigate the nefarious
businessman Aaron peel peel had ordered
the ghosts to kill his father and all
his partners and this was sort the
driving force of the season whilst the
season at ease that peel would be
selling a weapon to Raymond villanelles
old handler is actually turned out to be
digital data that was being collected on
everyone in the world and would provide
a wealth of blacklist material in the
end even villanelle reach peels filler
and the latter slits the tycoons throat
making him watch his own death in the
mirror while it's pretty much everyone
apparently didn't want them in hell to
do this it in fact him now that this had
been Caroline's plan the entire time and
this explain why mi6 was deliberately
not leaving a paper trail of the work
has pointed out
episode 4 due to there being no record
of villanelles association with mi6 the
death appeal can be written off as a
rogue assassination committed by the 12
and Constantine during cleanup Eve
realizes that she's been a porn the
entire time and that the mission had
always been to kill appeal rather than
to just collect information on him
Kenny paid lip service to this earlier
in the season after he was fired by
Caroline and pretty much leaves eve in
the same position that he was with no
evidence to prove anything
this leaves eve wondering whether she
can even continue working for the
government or if it's best that they
part ways adding to this divide Eve
herself has become a killer and whilst
the title of the show was always assumed
to be that villanelle would kill Eve it
actually means in some ways that Eve has
become a killer herself taking on the
moniker killing Eve throughout the
finale it's clear that this is what
villanelle once and she manipulates her
into killing Raymond Eve even adapts a
lot of the tactics that villanelle uses
such as using a maid's outfit to sneak
into places and it's clear she's
becoming a lot like the character that
she's been fixated upon for the last two
seasons it seems like villanelle because
of this is finally one however Eve
understands that she is a psychopath and
thus their definitions of love are
completely different villanelle sees
love his ownership which is why she
states at your mind in the episode when
asked you to find what it means
due to their thoughts on the matter
being polar opposites Eve walks away and
thus is shot and apparently killed for
it
now this is obviously going to be a big
point of contention with fans and as we
know from when villain outright issue
Constantine she's not very skilled with
a gun to me this is a little tit for tat
with villanelle deliberately doing this
as a sign of rejection that mirrors the
stabbing from the ending of the first
season
there's no way Eve is dead and with the
show being renewed for a third season we
will definitely be seeing a return of
the character in my opinion personally I
think at season 3 will flip villanelles
opening in this season and we follow as
Eve tries to recuperate before being
pulled back into the fray of mi6
similar to villanelles journey in this
season I can see Eve initially being
accepting of this however she will -
like villanelle did break the shackles
at her contractors have overheard
and go up on her own perhaps even in the
Bonnie and Clyde way that Bill and I
wanted but the finale of the third
season going into the fourth I can see
the two pairing up and taking down the
twelve Constantine and mi6 in order to
finally break free of their control and
to live their own lives possibly
together though it depends on where the
villanelle can learn to love or not add
a lot of fun with this season and the
black comedy aspect to it makes a really
great watch that had me gripped
throughout massively looking forward to
season three I can't wait to see what
the BBC have in store for us down the
line
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and if you agree with my take on
the ending or not comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of all the
episodes of season 5 of black mirror
which would be linked at the end as you
could probably hear I've still got a
really bad throat so thank you for
bearing with me through this video as I
croak Lee try to explain things and I
much appreciate it if you made it this
far
Cheers this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]